he just said you've been exposed to
asbestos unfortunately it's incurable
Rose has been diagnosed with
mesothelioma an asbestos related cancer
with a two percent survival rate my
first thought was
gosh Too Young To Die
because they said it was incurable
and obviously I was scared as how I
could explain this to my daughters my
two daughters for Generations asbestos
was commonly used in buildings up to
1999. I did know of asbestos but I
didn't feel
threatened by it was threatening me
because I didn't even
know about much about it really
did you ever think it would be the kind
of illness that you could ever get or
someone that you could ever get
absolutely not
never never crossed my mind at all
although banned for over 20 years
asbestos is still causing a shocking
number of mortalities there are over
five thousand asbestos related deaths
per year in the UK and it's estimated
that around 300 000 non-domestic
buildings contain some form of asbestos
including schools community centers and
hospitals and up to one million domestic
premises
unions are calling on the government to
remove all asbestos in public buildings
to protect workers especially
construction workers who are the most
likely to be affected the government's
current policy is that asbestos is safe
if it's left in situ and it's not
Disturbed but we would say asbestos will
always be disturbed especially in
buildings like schools where you've got
children running around that are falling
apart a lot of schools are at risk of
collapse currently it needs to be
removed we contacted the department of
work and pensions for comment but they
deferred us to the health and safety
executive which said that rushing to
remove asbestos from buildings would
pose more risk than managing it safely
but MPS want to see tougher action and
specific targets to rid the UK of this
deadly substance first of all I'd like a
register of all buildings all types of
buildings throughout the UK that has
Asbestos and then the second thing let's
set a timetable to get rid of this stuff
out of out of homes and out of
businesses and out of public buildings
across the whole of the country for
people like rose the growing cause for
change will be a welcome step in the
right direction
it's taking too many lives
not losing too many people
through this Mari Aurora Sky News